hi guys my name is my birth weight I'm
the Technical Specialist at Wolfram
research in Europe and today I'll be
presenting the cloud-connected for Excel
good afternoon everybody my name is mark
Braithwaite I am a technical specialist
at all from research Europe so I'm based
in the UK the reason I'm telling you
this before I start is because my job
essentially is to find all our
interesting new technologies learn as
much as I can about them and then
present them in talks such as this so
cloud connector was the next interesting
technology I found that I wanted to
present to you guys so to start with
what actually is cloud connector so this
is quickly a brief summary of what I'm
going to go through I'm gonna go through
what is it
show you some live coding examples go
through the most recent updates on why
they're important and then some further
examples should I have the time so as I
said to start with the most important
thing is what is it specifically it's a
plugin for excel that allows you to
access the Wolfram language from
directly within a Excel workbook this is
actually quite important because it
obviously extends excels capabilities
beyond what you normally would have just
by adding in the capabilities all from
language interestingly enough it works
on both our public and private wolfram
clouds which is hint about one of the
updates I'm going to mention later and
it also allows server based computations
from within Excel allowing you to access
more power than you may possibly have on
your local machine if that is required
so some further information can be found
should you record which should you wish
for it at the Wolfram cloud connector
web site telling you much more than what
I will include here including more
information on the Wolfram enterprise
private cloud in case that is
particularly relevant for yourselves and
just in case that is not enough there is
indeed a extensive set of resources
including documentation and everything
just like pretty much every Wolfram
product you'll get your hands on lovely
extensive documentation
uh-huh and most importantly would be the
ability for the install and use section
giving you absolutely all the
information you could need on adding it
into Excel setting it up appropriately
creating your own EAP is more on that in
a minute and it's actual use from within
a workbook including a large
troubleshooting section just in case
very happy with that so this is the bit
where I get the most nervous about the
live coding so one of the key things
about wolff the Wolfram cloud connector
for Excel that I wish to stress to start
with is that I mentioned API is earlier
I will admit not everyone probably
probably much everybody here would be a
Wolfram expert in terms of the Wolfram
language and their coding in which case
you don't necessarily need an API to get
started as I said this is the nervous
bit so here I have my standard Excel
spreadsheet nothing but it clicks but
interesting about it so far apart from
this lovely Wolfram tab which I'm just
going to sign into so that's me
connected up or should be connected up
when I get my password right to our
public cloud allow me to do remote
computations so normally you would quite
happily sit there and do two plus two in
Excel nice simple using the cloud
connector for Excel I can do the same
thing remotely
and achieve the same results so far not
necessarily very impressive another
thing that I've discovered how to do in
Excel in my like half an hour tutorial
would be generating random numbers
interesting thing is obviously that's a
single random number again something you
can quite easily with your knowledge of
the language do in Excel like so
so again know I'm being given zero fair
enough
again similarities between the two but
accessing the Wolfram language from
within Excel this is the bit where it
tries what I believe it gets interesting
so you've just seen the use of the rand
function
he says try and remember how to use
Excel and you get a single number right
it's only a single number though and in
order to do and generate loads of those
I can imagine there's some Excel of
theists who will tell me off for that
but I would sit there and drag that out
that's kind of a boring manual task one
of the things we'll remember if you're
from the Wolfram language though is
actually the ability to generate
multiple random numbers so I'm just
going to grab that straight up put it
into a new cell and instead generate all
hundred probably gonna be interesting
ten random numbers he says realizing
these we've gotten something
that's it
thank you and I get ten random numbers
without having to sit there and drag
that out it's an API call I will admit
but allows you to generate numbers quite
quickly one thing they will admit that I
have found very very hard to do in Excel
would be the addition of currencies
adding currencies together have I gone
off-mike
whoa parity so okay so normally in order
to do the addition of currencies in
Excel you would have to sit there
manually find your exchange rates and
put it all in
so we'll do 12 pounds I'd need the
exchange rate and then how many dollars
then I have to sit there and go well
okay that needs to be 12 plus that cell
times that so I don't know about you
guys you need to make sure your exchange
rates there you need to make sure it's
up to date that kind of thing we all
know the Wolfram language could do that
all automatically it will find the
current exchange rate for you and it'll
quite happily sit there and do all those
calculations as I mentioned let's do
that from within Excel he says so
quantity
constitutes two arguments the first one
is gonna be the number and this is where
it gets interesting
1 2 3 4 hey [ __ ] pounds it's not the
most exciting thing then I've got to add
that to quantity of irrelevant dollars
as you can see it's not the prettiest of
code but that's because of Excel so
nothing I could do about that one u.s.
dollars but the important thing is once
you've done this once obviously you can
copy and paste they would all expect we
have that nope thanks for the catch I
told you it's nerve-racking doing live
coding plus the other quantity finish
that off then we can pick our two cells
it's the first one and the second one
and then so this obviously is going over
to Wolfram Alpha finding the exchange
rate and quite happily pulling that
information through so I don't have to
worry about making sure the exchange
rate in my workbook is up-to-date and I
can pull information remotely from the
web as well all within will one simple
little call something I will admit I
take for granted when I'm trying to do
this in an actual notebook back at the
office
there's just a few quick live
demonstrations on some of the things we
can do I say quick
so one of the features of the ability to
call any functionality from the Wolfram
language in Excel is the fact that it
has to be a pure function that you
actually call a function sorry just a
function and obviously 2+2 itself is not
actually a function you'd actually have
to put two plus a 2 plus 2 plus a 2
comma 2 and then in order for the is it
parser in order to accept it there needs
the ampersand at the end which I'll show
you later so some of the most recent
updates which we want to bring to your
attention is the fact that this is now
up for preview release you can quite
happily download it and have a go about
have a go with it yourself
most importantly we now have our public
cloud use as well so you no longer need
an EPC in order to access this as you
saw I just connected to our regular open
cloud signed in free account nothing
special and I can quite happily get
there and use the Excel connector cloud
connector for Excel as I've tried to
mention and demonstrate it a little bit
you can evaluate absolutely any wolfram
expression whatsoever there are some
very good examples on that coming up and
also you have the ability for
authentication so because you were
calling api's the wolf farm system
allows you to specify that those api's
need to have an authenticated wolfram
account which means you can then set it
to either specific users or just anybody
who has a wolfram ID so you can deploy
your api and only individual or certain
individuals can then access it so one of
them slightly more prepared examples
would be the use of temporal data so one
of the brilliant things about this cloud
connector is that it does actually pass
more than just the numerical value back
in a lot of cases it does actually pass
the back information such as the fact
that it's a date so formatted as a date
so instead of coming up with some clever
way of deciding what it is I'm
attempting to do
it's date range sorry so I'm just gonna
create a series of dates with a bit of
wolf farm code which I'm used to using
all the time as opposed to having to
figure out how to do this in gonna
choose three for now close that one I'd
be sad finish and I'll get it to my
fault I've taken too long just quickly
sign out so I can again
built-in timeout I can't do anything
with and I can generate a series of
dates today and the next three days as
you can see it's formatted and
appropriate to a date in this case
thankfully has recognized that I am from
the UK so it's put the day first as well
which is quite useful for me if I
particularly want to I can then set it
so it will happily accept a date a
number from within the notebook press
ENTER and it will continue and now I can
just edit this three and convert it to
ten and so on so forth and a lot date
appropriately if I wanted to I could
choose a hundred and it's a single API
call as opposed to many or several
calculations which really does help and
as you can see it's automatically
adapting to exactly what I've asked it
for I'm not having to specify how much
space you can or can use or anything
like that it's automatically done all
the formatting for me one of the things
that I have kind of sidestepped from was
the mention of ap ice
I will admit there are going to be users
who are brilliant in Excel and can do
all sorts of amazing stuff but might not
necessarily be so versed in the Wolfram
language coding that's where the ability
to set up api's comes in which you can
set up your own API hide all the lovely
amazing coding in the background so
these people don't have to sit there and
try read it and understand it and they
can call it more simply from within
Excel without having to worry about all
that kind of Wolfram coding so let's see
if this will go according to plan okay
so simply I'd need a cloud deploy of an
API function helps the variable type it
in property
then all I need to do is figure out
exactly what I'm attempting to do here
in terms of the temporal data so I'm
going to recreate what I've just shown
you on screen using the Wolfram ability
if I can remember what code is for it so
I need to tell it what I'm looking for
so I will admit I have forgotten my code
so I'm going to use my old cheat here I
started so all I need to do is tell it
what it's looking for which in this case
is a bit of data from within the Excel
spreadsheet so in this case it's a
repeat it's not a repeating event in
this case it's just going to be a single
number when it accepts that number I
need to tell it what to do with it so in
this case I was doing the date range I'm
going to save you guys watching me type
it up come on
heading back over here
grab that piece of coding
paste it straight in here so I've
extracted all that information that
normally people would have to the Excel
users would have to know set up in my
API function I want permissions to go to
public so that anybody here could use it
if they so choose and then I can deploy
that so I've deployed my API not the
best idea I must admit let's give it a
name so I can find it easier I'll call
it WTC cloud connector for Excel so I
now have my API which I've gone is
stored in the public cloud which is
public use to anybody you guys could all
sit there and use that now right now if
you so wish it's entirely up to you and
I'm going to do the exact same thing
just by doing equals Wolfram API you
don't need the name of the API which I
left in my notebook so I did lame it
correctly so it's WTC cloud connector
for Excel 2018 I need a parameter to
grab that quickly
it's my spelling is atrocious when I get
nervous you guys hear me yeah cool and
that parameter
it's about this is Excel is that cell
there helps wick in the right place that
parameter is there
I forgot syntax data
yep API cannot be found
open ecstasy in it see that is why you
double-check everything what have I
missed
no data whatever I set my API at well
yep that's my fault so something in my
API that I created myself is incorrect
data guessing number date range today
puss okay but the idea is that as you
can see from the Excel spreadsheet
itself that is a lot easier for people
to type in when it comes to using the
work Excel workbook and can hide quite a
lot of interesting complex coding which
pretty much anybody can then get access
to all they need to know is what they're
passing in is each individual a little
bit which quite easily try pass over to
some individual without them having to
know the Wolfram language coding and
they can access that API however you so
choose remembering the authenticate a
bit or in this case as I showed you
public my next example is a bit more
interesting so here I have an example
data set that I have found on a free
information sharing website and I can
quite happily show you that there are
some things such as financial prediction
which I find the Wolfram language does a
bit better than I can possibly manage in
Excel because I already have my
knowledge of the Wolfram language so
large spreadsheet of data quite a bit of
computational power required but
thankfully head over to the wolf or to
the Wolfram cloud and I can get a lovely
financial prot including prediction
which is absolutely tiny which you can't
see this lovely little orange spec just
there this is a financial prediction of
what should continue in terms of this
company's particular profits over a
period of time I don't know if you
spotted but that coding was again
interesting
mostly due to the syntax required by
Excel but this time more successfully I
already have a API I deployed earlier
which I can call to do the exact same
thing again with after after abstracting
and hiding all the complicated coding
which we know is not actually that
complicated but still that's that's not
my API
okay and very imaginatively I've called
it something very similar which will
then do again in this case there is a
significantly larger amount of data
going into it but we'll do the same
financial prediction using the Wolfram
engine which I know for a fact is
actually quite difficult to set up and
program within Excel setup we different
parameters all that kind of thing
and have quite a lot of interesting
things going on whereas the wolf plan
which you can't actually do it in a very
short and simple line of code so just to
quickly recap you can run any Wolfram
language expression whatsoever from
within Excel using the cloud connector
you can use simple functions the Wolfram
and the Wolfram API function in order to
call the Wolfram language from a cloud
source into your workbook you can either
use the Wolfram language expressions
which you all know how to use or you can
make it even simpler on and on Wolfram
expert to use those that same
functionality through the use of API and
also you can authenticate those API so
that only individual certain users can
use them by logging in first thank you
very much for listening do we have any
questions